Welcome to the show.
We're a sort of crossing the Rubicon in a
sense on the topic of impeachment proceedings.
It's against Donald Trump.
Uh, we have a new poll up on the community
tab of the David Pakman show, youtube channel,
asking what you think is going to happen.
Uh, but we now have sitting senators who are
calling for the impeachment of Donald Trump,
not just at political events, but on the Senate
floor.
And I'm talking about Democratic Senator Elizabeth
Warren, who is also running for president
for the Democratic nomination in 2020.
Um, we've heard it from the house, but this
is a, uh, a much bigger deal because sitting
active members of the Senate saying on the
Senate floor that it's time for impeachment
proceedings against the president of the United
States to start is very different than a member
of the house who have with, with peace and
love.
We respect and understand are important members
of, uh, the American political establishment.
This is a senator during live speeches on
the house of the Senate.
Take a look at Elizabeth Warren yesterday.
So nef here to bring an impeachment proceeding
and forth for us, for this body, for Congress
to back up from that and to say that protecting
the president is more important than protecting
the constitution is not only wrong, it is
a file location of our oath of office.
I'm here to say one more time in publicly,
this is not a fight I wanted to take on, but
this is the fight in front of a snail.
This is not about politics.
This is about the constitution of the United
States of America.
We took an oath not to try to protect Donald
Trump.
We took an oath to protect the con and serve
the constitution of the United States of America,
and the way we do that is we begin impeachment
proceedings.
Now against this president, Mr President,
I yield a fork
sitting senators calling for impeachment of
a sitting president is a big deal.
Don't let you know, Trump will frame this
as, who knows, wacky Pocahontas or whatever
he likes to say about Elizabeth Warren.
Remember how badly Republicans hated Barack
Obama?
I mean deeply, they hated him, but they knew
he didn't actually do anything worthy of impeachment.
You had Senator Jon Kyl who said about President
Obama.
Impeachment is always a possibility, but no
one is talking about that.
He said that on a radio show about Barack
Obama.
You had senator James Inhofe, who's out of
his mind who said Obama could be impeached
over the supposed Bengazi cover up.
Turns out there was no such cover up and no
one actually tried to impeach President Obama
for that.
Uh, no senators actually tried to do that.
Senator Tom Coburn during the Obama era, said
in a political setting, Obama is getting close
to having done enough to justify impeachment.
It wasn't true, but that was at a town hall
meeting.
It wasn't on the floor of the Senate.
If you go back to George W. Bush, for example,
I mean, no senators, democratic or Republican,
we're saying it's time to impeach George W.
Bush.
Uh, uh, uh, and the reason why is that senators
on the floor of the Senate don't say that
a president should be impeached if they actually
haven't done anything worthy of it.
Democratic Speaker of the house, Nancy Pelosi,
though I was taking a bit of a different approach.
She is further resisting impeachment.
She says, Trump is goading us to impeach him
and then it would actually help Donald Trump
to solidify his base.
Now I hate to break it to Nancy Pelosi, but
Donald Trump's base is very solid, right?
28% of the country has already said they're
definitely voting for Donald Trump in 2020.
His base isn't moving, but that's more of
a political calculation that Nancy Pelosi
seems to be making.
Elizabeth Warren is laying it out in clearer
terms.
This is not about politics.
This is about facts and the law and the constitution.
Uh, the, the question of the political strategy
is a legitimate one and I think it's actually
a question as to whether it is good political
strategy to try to impeach a Donald Trump.
But the actions at this point are there.
That's the reality.
And now that being said, no one should jump
the gun on impeachment.
Step one is just debate, uh, on the floor
of the House of Representatives that that
is just the first step here.
Trump's administration won't even comply with
the most minor oversight requests for records,
for documents, for testimony.
That is part of the obstruction for which
this house floor debate on impeachment actually
should be happening.
Start the debate, have the debate about impeachment
in the house.
Use that to gather evidence.
Use that to publicize what it is that has
been done.
Use it to get people to understand what's
in the molar report.
Because as I've said before, too many Americans
simply haven't read them all a report and
they're operating sort of under the guise
of this, no collusion, no obstruction PR campaign
meme that Donald Trump and William Barr have
pretty damn successfully mounted.
So start the debate and use the debate in
the house to collect the evidence.
Go where the evidence takes you, but it is
time to formally start the impeachment debate
on the floor of the House of Representatives.
Period.
Get Robert Mueller to the house and have him
answer the question.
Would Donald Trump be facing criminal obstruction
charges?
If he was not president of the United States
molar, we'll of course give a diplomatic noncommittal
answer and say, oh, that's a hypothetical,
but he won't be able to say no.
The president would not be facing obstruction
charges if he were not president of the United
States because the answer is yes, Trump would
be indicted for obstruction if he were not
a sitting president.
Good for Elizabeth Warren for calling it for
what it is.
Let's now see if other senators join her.
There are other senators, a democratic senators
who are running for president.
Uh, some of them have said in a nonsense it
settings that they believe that the time,
at least for the debate about impeachment
is here.
Let's hear from commonwell Harris on the floor
of the Senate.
Let's hear from Cory booker on the floor of
the Senate and see if we can get multiple
sitting senators saying in open Senate session,
it is time to start a impeachment proceedings.
If not, at least impeachment debate about
the president of the United States.
Do not let Trump trick you into believing
that this is just no big deal.
This is very rare.
This doesn't often happen during uh, in American
politics to presidents of the United States.
It's a big
deal
and we're going to be paying attention to
it.